good morning belief nation if you're
having a hard time making a decision
where everybody is telling you to do one
thing and you you feel in your gut that
you want to take it in a different
direction I'm gonna share an inspiring
clip from Donald Trump that I think will
help sometimes in life to be successful
oftentimes most of the time you have to
follow your instincts you have to follow
your gut you have to your parents may
say wrong your whoever may say wrong but
you have to do it so for me this all
comes down to making decisions with your
heart versus your head and I've always
said and for those who've been on my
channel while you have to make big
decisions with your heart and small ones
with your head most people do the
opposite they make all decisions based
on their head and I get it it makes
sense right it's the logical thing to do
it's the same thing to do it's according
to the data and the numbers and it's
what everybody else has always done but
that's not how you have a great impact
on the world if you look at the people
who've done great things you look at the
people who've literally changed the
world it's because they refuse to listen
to the data they refuse to listen to the
way that had always been done and they
trusted their gut to create something
amazing you can look at Steve Jobs who
started Apple computers at a time when
everybody thought there's no way people
would ever need a personal computer
there was zero market for a personal
computer the data said this is a stupid
thing to do and yet he built Apple to be
the most valuable company in the world
when Richard Branson starts new
businesses he says he never involves
accountants in the startup phase he
brings him in later on but never in the
startup phase because he wants people
who are dreamers he wants people who can
change the way the landscape is right
now he wants people who will act with
their heart and not be logical because
when you are starting that business you
don't want to make the most logical safe
decision you know this from your own
personal experience in your life as well
for those of you who are married like I
am
why did you marry your husband or wife
was it because it was logical was it
because everything lined up you know you
made your pros and cons list and there
were more pros and cons and it was a
logical safe thing to do no that's not
what leads to a happy marriage you
trusted your heart I recently got into a
fight with another guy on Twitter on a
recent Twitter chat we were talking
about making decisions and I said that
big decisions with your heart small
stays with your head and he wrote back
to say nope you're wrong Evan what you
need to do is make decisions base with
your head and your heart and that guy
just doesn't get it because usually your
heart what your hearts telling you to do
is the exact opposite of what your head
is telling you to do that's why there's
such a conflict because your gut is
telling you really want to go here I
really want to go do this thing but
everything is telling me all the data
all my friends all the stats are saying
this is not ever gonna work out on big
decisions your head and your heart or
rarely align and if you want to win you
want to live a life with no regrets you
want to have a big impact on the world
you want to have a massively successful
company then on those big decisions
listen to your heart and not your head
believe so my question today today is
I'd love to know your experience I'd
love to know a time in your life when
your head and your heart were combating
each other and how you made that
decision whether you listen to your
heart and you're happy with it or you
listened to your head and you regret it
share your story leave in the comments
below I want to see it I want to hear it
and I think it could also inspire
everybody else is watching so thank you
for watching this episode continue to
believe have an amazing day and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot event spresso